you've been in so many great films any
movies you regret turning down a lot
yeah yeah
is there one movie that it just kills
you that you turned it down there is it
not feel a little so I'm gonna tell the
story cuz you're onto something but I
did see the guy who directed it the
other day and now I'm insecure about
telling it natella okay listen
reality bites just came out on these
knees right yeah I'm gettin everyone's
like I'm getting off ha yeah yeah 90
right well what am i doing I'm like
driving across country with a friend of
mine we're literally decided like
wouldn't it be fun to tell you the state
of mind I was in my friend met me in
Austin we're gonna drive from Austin to
New York and halfway through we decided
it'd be more fun to go to four corners
New Mexico right and we just did that
what you're in your 20s you're goofing
around you're driving I got the script
at Independence Day and I start reading
Independence Day yeah yeah yeah I left
that part out yes they send you the
script into Penn State and they're like
saying you can do this in like this like
you know dollar bills attest to it yeah
I mean and I'm like and I'm such a big
shock I think I'm so cool and I'm
reading it to my buddy in the car I'm
like isn't it's a bad line et phone home
that's stupid
you know what I mean and I'm like I'm
going through it to the point where I
literally throw it out
you threw the stripper interfacing out
the window on a road onto the Texas
Highway okay I'll cut to cut you nuts
your Will Smith's driving down the
highway
no this is to this is true I can't
believe it
listen to this right so the next you
know the next summer I'm dating this
girl a wonderful woman she is going to
school at UT and it's fourth of July and
everybody wants to go to the movies
right we're with a big group of people
well let's go to movies what do you want
to go see it everything let's go see you
dependence day I'm like all right I'm
sure yeah this'll be this will be
amusing just go see how bad this is I
walk in to the theater obviously it's
completely sold out right you cannot get
in
Will Smith says you know et phone home
boom I mean they basically get a
standing ovation in the middle of the
movie right and I'm sitting there guy
going I really didn't get the joke and I
told Lynn afterwards I said it wasn't
that good though was it I mean I know
everybody else loved it but it wasn't
that good music it was really good yeah
and it still is
you